well another beautiful morning I'm
always fat in the morning times it's
time to get a lot of things done and
dogs and things I got to do every
morning those get woke up by these damn
squirrels and they're out there stealing
my dog food I see a squirrel right there
eating my dog food these guys tear holes
into my 67 dollar bag of dog food every
one of those little pellets that they
eat actually costs a lot of money I
don't like killing things but you know
what it goes right in the dog pop turned
it into dog food just throw it in the
cooker with fish or meat whatever I got
while I'm cooking up I want to let it go
to waste resources are resources out
here you know a lot of people would
probably laugh at me for cooking up
squirrels for my dogs but I'm not gonna
just leave them rotten in the woods and
waste
a little excited there shot too soon I
want to kill them I don't want to leave
them to go off and suffer in the brush
you know I got a bunch of dog food here
and see these squirrels have eaten away
and did you know this here is some super
quality chicken and beef and pork scraps
this is their base food here it's a real
high-grade kibble you know keeps these
dogs going these kind of dogs need a lot
of calories so I don't want to let
squirrels be eating my expensive dog
food this gun I wouldn't say it's the
most accurate or best gun you know but
uh sure works are blessing squirrels
squirrel
your school can use easy doesn't come in
and get this dog thing take my time with
this one this is what I call protecting
my investment
you just ran right on off you're pretty
quick like that I don't think this guns
actually shooting that straight it's
kind of old and rickety been beat around
in dog sleds and I kind of decided it in
because I'd rather do they die fast so I
can throw them the dog cooker this thing
isn't really seeming to be shooting
that's great I'm gonna take this can and
go see what's going on with it